youtubers live too
five years ago it's been five years
since i played the first one and here we
are baby
back getting the game
fun fact i am in this game i can't wait
to see how i'm gonna look like
[Music]
it's gonna be the most meta thing i'll
play
as myself myself doing youtube while
doing youtube
nice
were they being even more meta there
where i play
youtubers life while playing youtubers
live
i don't appreciate that okay let's go to
port
because they have a gym and i gotta get
swole should i play as myself or should
i play like the ultimate youtuber i
think i should play as myself even
though it'd be weird to bump into myself
while playing myself
while bumping into myself while playing
myself is this my beard i never know how
to do like
this is not my color obviously but this
is not my color either which is my color
i'll go with poopy brownie looks like my
haircut gotta get the black t-shirt
oh yeah
no yeah yeah this is what i actually
wear fun fact that's why you never see
my legs in my videos
all right heading down to tubertown
oh don't jump too high man you don't
want to do that trust me
looks like they put a lot of effort into
this one
if you guys want to check out the game
yourself there's a referral link in the
description
savior looks like he's been doing
youtube for too long man all right
we got a drone cam okay
slime
easy
loading personality
let's go
what's my name i guess i'll go felix
shelburn
all right here we go my first vlog guys
how many subscribers do i have as we go
bryce
it's me well my first vlog will be
something like
hey guys shyly yeah exactly
yes
[Music]
bad joke
constructively same criticism while you
flatter yourself think of a good piece
of information have a laughing fit yeah
i laugh when i'm nervous so
that would make sense
you sign off and it's over hell no gotta
ask for subscribers by the way guys if
you haven't hit the notification bell on
this video already that's right i'm
doing youtube while playing youtube
that's how we do this i've done my first
vlog baby let's go now go edit it save
no
no i have to edit my own video
oh
god i've no the pre-save arrow the dark
ages of youtube
okay so i need to connect them
there's like a little latch to connect
to
no i wasn't very good let's move these
two
that's better i accidentally deleted all
my progress nice
okay there it is thumbnail
yeah i'm looking angry i'll title it
pewdiepie mental breakdown not epic
that's a clickbait
this is how i sit in front of him
before i publish a video 100
what why no one likes it
oh
sad scythe help me cyber we need to do
your life you lose now
asap
side please
my views oh gotta check the youtube app
zero subscribers rest in pepperoni
smoony no
why
what did i do wrong
did did you know you can also record
commentary scripts scripts are a type of
video okay we're gonna have to try and
get 30 subs by recording a commentary
script the ultimate form of comedy is
ridicule so we are going to do a
commentary
calling out pewdiepie hey what up we got
more confidence now i hate
pewdiepie i am better
sub to me instead
subscribe to me thanks
youtube really is that simple i get
questions all the time how do i get into
youtube
that's it that's it right there the best
commentary
seems about right no hyperbole there
two likes
legit
i was so hyped if i got like two likes
back in the day
no joke hey yeah it's it's just really
reminiscent to play yo my subs
back in the day on youtube there was a
feature called like it was like a
feature sub so if you subscribe to one
channel youtube asks okay do you want to
subscribe to all these other channels as
well and they kind of automatically did
it and i was featured by a bigger
channel once and i gained like 50
subscribers in a day because of it and i
was like
[Music]
it's all right i'm famous now like back
off peasants
it was such a big deal for me and then
when i had like 20 subs to just then
jump up 50. anyway let's go back to ben
enough of my chip chat but it would put
it
now unfortunately i've gotten so many
subscribers that there's literally no
point for me
i have nothing to strive for anymore but
i can do youtube just for fun you know i
mean
it's very liberating in that sense but
i'd be lying if i said sometimes i
didn't miss the hustle you know uh
savior likes my videos yeah he better
this is a normal thing that will happen
if you become a youtuber other people
will try and lead you off just like
we should make videos related to trends
that's right squid game is trending
right now we got to make a video maybe
like a squid game in real life video
that'd be sick oh cool i get to decorate
uh gaming corner let's go rotate oh
that's hella cozy that looks comfy as
hell
talk to blair where's blair
maybe she's outside
okay sorry but now the game is not
realistic youtubers we don't go outside
but i guess is she blair are you player
who's blair
yo jacksepticeye in this game i knew it
i kinda liked the style of the game
it's weird
i got she be kinda
okay she should be
uh i wonder what these games are we got
pubg lara croft what is that what's the
last one
dark souls i don't know
are you blair you're blair hello blair
give me games
oh
thanks
gotta got the new game should i order
the game online um
[Music]
should i earn the game online no i'll
walk to blair in the game
yeah i have gotta run back record the
video and upload it before anyone else
youtube is not about who makes the
better videos is no matter who does it
first everyone else will be copying me
fools fools
deity of war nice now we can record our
first game play let's go i got the
elgato ready let's go gameplay time
to start the video how's it going bros
i'm so excited for this new game
check out my referral link
and
ship me and jacksepticeye
we are so beautiful maybe i'll play with
him if this video gets five thousand
likes i play yeah yeah
let's get real here no one watches me
for insightful content subscribe
that was a good video i felt i feel
hyped to upload that one oh it's kind of
fun looking at youtube and like a weird
outside perspective
it's kind of funny i remember back in
the day like everyone would be very
literal with their titles which i think
is good right it's kind of annoying with
all the clickbait epic gameplay
um
but i remember my
my grandma who runs an art gallery she
was always telling me when i used to do
art to never name your artwork literally
what it is and just have something
that's more interesting and draw people
in and i always apply that to titles and
i always felt like that really helped me
fun facts guys fun facts gosh it's go to
bed i'm tired
okay getting the hang of it how many
subs 73 that's crazy
we're gonna be big in no time pewdiepie
is gonna talk to me soon i feel it got
instagram
oh blair is so popular huh yeah well
what about me i'm popular too
i gotta take a photo of my new gaming
setup then
yes
sharded we're going for the intellectual
audience on this
what the hell can i see my panties
oh lame
yo 193 likes damn bye i'm coming for you
i'm going to make another video i need
more subs
full of energy
grab that attention right away that's
what you want and then reel them in with
some information
make sure to build yourself uh
and then ask for subs
always ask for subs subscribe and turn
notification bell guys i'm really asking
for subs too late i should all you
should always ask at the start of the
video that makes the most amount of
sense why wouldn't people want to
subscribe to you right away before they
watch the video to see if it's good
enough i really think the whole video
should be about why you should subscribe
i'm feeling this video is not going to
do well uh i have two haters
when there's a video that has no
dislikes on it yet have you ever hit
this like on it because if you have
you're going to you're going to do it
bad places you know that right why would
you do that it always perplexed me i'm
like bro why
why you gotta be that everyone else like
the video you can just leave okay
anyway
what was your photo with a play con uh
playcon i don't know what that is i
gotta be honest with you are you a
playcon cool
i need to work on my social skills
actually it doesn't matter i'm a
youtuber this is a play con got it it's
me kissing jacksepticeye
me and bae nice
getting more subs this is going great
we can record a video here
outside i'm too awkward to do that are
you kidding me
all right let's do it you're running out
of energy no
this is about right i need to buy g fuel
time to shoot the vlog
hey guys i'm giving away a lamborghini
to myself um if you want me to give a
lamborghini to myself smash like on this
video and subscribe there we go watch
cass is the biggest trend right now
maybe i should go to the i'll head to
the game store and buy watch cats
yeah yeah i gotta play watch catch god
god damn it doesn't matter if i want to
play it it's what the people want this
game is too real man
68 you're really out here naming it 68.
all right let's play watch cats oh i'm
gonna get so many views
what's up guys watch cats is my favorite
game even though i never played it i'm
having a great time playing this game i
skipping through all the games
and subscribe
[Music]
oh look at the camera quality
it's too real it's too real all right
now we just got edited you know what
there it is
easy edit
literally just drag the files into
premiere and did nothing to them now
give me views come on come on it's gonna
go viral
let's go
watch catch okay now i sleep
it's the life of a youtuber
oh i'm trending today
let's go
clara wants a selfie all right claire
here you go
this is selfie
there you go clara i'm changing the
youtube game because i'm trending what
did i do did i make an oversee
cyberware blair got the latest hookup
she doesn't have it but you suck
you slice
go home boy
uh sketchy guy hey you got the game you
got the goods
if you want cyberware you will have to
go to the port and look for one of my
colleagues okay
there he is found yeah give me the game
i've been told that there's been a
superstar youtuber uh-huh i wonder who
they're hitting at i need to get him to
endorse my work then he'll give me a
copy of the game are you serious
are you joking
search for a famous youtuber uh
if he's where i think he is the youtuber
looking for is blonde and has beard will
you find where he is
hey yeah he's in him yeah you've seen
people
yeah
a journalist came to my house once and
he said that i was like how the hell did
you get my address and he's like i just
went to a pub and asked i'm like i don't
believe you but okay also get the hell
out of my house
hey where's pupa
i want to get into the club
damn it
where's pupa oh it's been seen down time
okay
oh my god all the references uh he ain't
here you pretty fine
are you people
are you pewdiepie oh no i'm running out
of time
shoot i need to find pewdiepie are you
people
must
stalk
baby
crazy
hey mouse
hey max wait a minute
it must be at the convention of course
i'm stupid i never went inside
are you pewdiepie no
damn it where is he i'm not gonna
interview cinnamon toast ken i want
pewdiepie i need validation from real
youtubers
called out maybe the game store maybe
he's at the game store pewdiepie is at
the game store here
hey
at the game store main is this his house
yes yes i found him there's pewdiepie
and he's walking my
uh let's go
he looks just like me
oh my god there he is it's pewdiepie and
his little dog
is there's somebody that doesn't work
and and gosh and that's why a very
suspicious guy was offering access to
cyberware this morning people are going
nuts about this and it looks really bad
bro has he offered it to you yes but i
need to support a super youtuber
i have an idea
bro
i take a signed photo of me so he sees
we know each other and gives you access
to the game
bro your drone will let me know me when
you have it let's go to your house we'll
record a video together and find out
what cyberware is hiding maya will take
you where you live she's got an
incredible sense of smell what do you
think
hell yeah okay let's make it casuals
okay bro
i'm carrying a photo of myself
let's go
where it where was he i'm never gonna
find him again dang it stupid pewdiepie
i was there at the game store oh my gosh
i went everywhere but the game store all
right
so pewdiepie is waiting for you at your
home to record a video
i'm sorry who gave me keys to my own
home i don't think so out of my way bozo
i gotta collab with pewdiepie this is
what ken must feel every time he records
with me the incredible oh my god bro you
got the game i'm wondering what we'll
find when we play let's record that
video like i'm gonna record with some
random as a youtuber where only a
thousand subscribers i don't think so
are you just gonna stand in that this is
like me recording with conan
sure i'll oh you you you do your thing
conan i'll just stay in the bed
[Music]
oh god
this is too many memories that i wish i
never had
standing off yeah it would be a casual
that we collaborated nice
it's so boring is this the hit game i
was talking about it's so short
i know that feeling all these games get
hyped up and then you as a youtuber are
equally let down man i don't even get
hyped for games anymore because of it
but it's okay we got to collaborate with
peter pack
i basically sold out okay i knew it they
wanted to promote a crappy product by
using youtubers who take cheap brags you
have to enter the message thread so that
with your talent as a youtuber you can
report the scam first we have to catch
this sales guy wherever he is do you
know where to look well i mean he's
probably in there
almost but not quite maya has tracked
him down he's downtown then why did you
ask we'll catch a scammer i have to go
and look for my first seat
let's go uh hold up bro i gotta edit my
video
oh that's a banger even though it's a
scam i'm still gonna upload my video
obviously i got pewdiepie's leggings in
the video
pewdiepie legging video
i should have titled it pewdiepie leg
video oh my god i would have gotten up
i'm getting a billion views oh cool so
you get new cards
and make a bad joke never done that
listen cyberware is a full-sized pizza i
love
pizza these greedy game developers they
just want to hype up the games and then
sell it for 60 buckaroonies
hi bro you came maya found the
salesperson and look we caught him
red-handed doing business with giggy
macaroni two together less trustworthy
than an orc in an elevator let's record
a video to report for just
likes to record a video and report this
giggy rubber loony brother booney let's
record a videot
well i don't have energy i don't have
energy i'm doing it anyway okay we're
live streaming we're live on twitch i
mean over youtube of course okay we're
live
what's up brows okay oh wait what this
is different left
live oh killing it oh killing it oh
you're going down giggy why do i look so
sad i'm literally
i was killing it nice
got him they caught me doe-handed at
least i got out of the pizza street why
is all this about pizza good job maya by
the way it is kind of awesome seeing me
in the game i don't know why
maybe i'm just myself
egocentric let's go
mine is so cute i like how edgar didn't
get any recognition
it's all about maya i'm the story thanks
for not scamming your subscribers to get
money integrity integrity zoe by
integrity when a youtuber and so many
people watch your videos you have to be
aware how important the things you say
and you are did i did pewdiepie just
tell me that
please
let's go
[Laughter]
oh
i got a whoa bro let's go feel this good
jibber
thank you thank you i remember also like
the excitement of going to bed when you
knew you uploaded a really good video
and knowing that you were going to read
comments and when you woke up
it's so
fun
look at that all right what an epic day
in the life of on the life of youtuber's
life right if you want to check out this
game i'm going to live stream it as well
in a couple days
but if you're gonna download it you're
still in the description it's a referral
so i appreciate it and uh
yeah seems pretty fun so far i enjoyed
thanks for watching remember to
subscribe and hit the bell thing hit the
bell thing that's what we're doing now
no more asking for subscribers
bell hit the bell
bell
bell hit the bell hit the bell bro hit
it now
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out